so like everyone else on the planet or
at least everyone with a brain i am
incredibly excited though so rude of me
incredibly excited to see your series um
what are you most excited for people to
actually see in it i think
kaza doom
alive
and well and thriving and very much in
power and
not a tomb um
and all the details and dimensions of
the kingdom and uh the dwarfs in it um
yes being dwarves obviously i'm excited
to kind of to introduce
um the fans to a thriving casual cousin
i like learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of a series or a
movie so i'm curious for fans of lord of
the rings like is there anything that
they might be surprised to learn about
the actual making of the show
i mean there are so many so many
trickery that that happens on there
actually you know what no they will be
surprised that a lot of the set is
actually right in front of us
um there was there was a huge effort and
a big push to
um to make everything as real as
possible um
and not kind of heavily laden with with
with cgi so i think that you might be
surprised that
you know what you're actually looking at
was there on the day and we are looking
at it
well i mean talk a little bit about how
that uh helps you as an actor because i
know so many actors now are working with
the volume technology and other new
technology to make it seem like it's
there but it's really not i mean what
was it like actually walking through
these sets and seeing it so alive it was
just brilliant it just made everything
so
um
easy and exciting to play with because
we could see it we could feel it and we
had this perfect balance and medley of
all with a brilliant technology and
brilliant minds um but also as owen said
the material that we could touch and
feel and so everything that we're
playing and the story that we're telling
with any external forces and with each
other is authentic and it's real and um
you know we understand it uh as it's
staring right back at us yeah i mean
all of the sets kind of you know in a
studio you'd have different worlds and
it's kind of this is middle earth middle
earth was created right in front of our
eyes and it kind of really felt that
as you walked onto set which is
half the battle i suppose yeah without
spoilers which episode of the eight is
your favorite and why
let's
go
with
seven i can't tell you why because
[Laughter]
sure i'm not to give you a give anything
away you could have done but no
um
yeah episode 7 is is is quite special
i'm going to echo a line on that and i'm
going to say 7.
i'm going to say 7 because
there is so much
wonderfulness in some of those moments
my last thing for you guys how would you
actually describe the scale and scope of
the series
fantastic yeah yeah it's epic
monumental it is oh all of those big
words
that's how i would describe it
um
yeah it's there isn't enough words
to describe it quite frankly it's um
it's huge and it's fantastical and a joy
to be a part of on that note i cannot
wait to talk more specifically with the
two of you congrats on being part of the
series and thank you for your time thank
you so much